hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on utilizing a
multiplexed mrm panel for in vitro and
in vivo monitoring of lysosomal
dysfunction in the cns
by paul auger a senior scientist in the
dmpk department at the denali
therapeutics and i'm susie valdez of lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's event before we begin i want to
encourage you to engage with us you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation just simply type them in to
the ask a question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on the support tab on the top
right hand corner or use that ask a
question on the left side please join me
now in welcoming our presenter paul
auger
you may now begin your presentation
welcome paul
you my name is paul auger i'm from
denali therapeutics and i'm talking to
you about utilizing a multiplexed mrn
panel from bone and viva monitoring of
lysosomal dysfunction
um quick intro um some of the effects
i'm going to cover
for today i'm looking a little bit about
this malfunction neurodegenerate
um i'll talk about these mass spectrum
neurodegeneration
and uh i'll go on details about
multiplex protein panels for biomarker
pathway analysis uh looking at all the
mass effect side in as well as some of
the the ways that we do qc metrics
and um we'll look at a little bit of
data from the dsf and cellular model
we've applied this method too
a brief over the way that denali sort of
uh goes up looking at neurodegeneration
so
denali employs the pathway focused to
drug development
so uh we have the
the targets that we come up with
are through human genetics and from what
we call degenerate genes so sodiums that
relate to generation
uh um we've broken these energy a number
of pathways around lysosomal
function gliobiotic and cellular
hydrosis and so
today i'm going to this is almost
um
but the pier in terms of license covers
there's a number of targets that we have
in in some therapies that have an equine
clinic but we'll be kicking about that
today in depth
so so targeting lysosomal function
generation the way that we do this
internally is
um or the way we thought about this is
that there are a number of things that
that sort of regulate or observable
dysfunction um there's cellular stress
give genetic you have environmental
factors
um and so
in in sort of the lessonable dysfunction
state is a reduced protein degradation
um you can get protein aggregation and
things like land or lewy body and
bodies and then when you get those
aggregations you'll start to get
neuronal generation
and um from that you'll get the the
death of the
neurons um so so the general hypothesis
uh that we we've kind of modeled our
lysosomal dysfunction around is that
it's a pathology of parkinson's and it
leads to the protein aggregation of
alpha-syncline in the
lewy bodies it's so part of their
inflammation and the dopaminergic
neuron it's also indicated in other
neurodegenerative diseases so um
the [ __ ] today will really be around
some of the ways that we're looking at
parkinson's but we do use a lot of
function for other
um
other other therapeutic areas and other
targets
and um and so what we're trying to do
here with this with this multiplex panel
actually to kind of tie it all together
that we're looking at and developing a
way to develop and monitor this
regulation of the pathway to identify
potential biomarkers um
as early as possible
that i've worked or the way that our
proteomics has worked on on developing
proteomics ethanol is really looking at
it in
kind of buckets and so um so
what i have here is sort of the
the truck that we use to think about how
we're gonna do our proteomics work and
so in really early stages of hypothesis
generation we do a lot of underrated
discovery so we do a mix of
dda dia and tp
we do less
label free quantitation
but um but we have implemented some of
that as well um from there we use those
targets to help build some of these
multiplex panels that we use uh in a
more broad sense and so we view this as
really a targeted discovery and um so
i'm focused on that today um about
target qualification um and looking at
really sort of these broad multiplexed
mrn assays that take data from the
untargeted side and and kind of put them
together create a more um the
quantitative panel that will allow us to
track changes in specific proteins and
protein pathways and then further down
the line in things that we do is that
once we really have validated some of
these targets in in this targeted
discovery assays we move them to what
you would call a clinical assay
development
these are more biomarker clinical
biomarker assays
on the peptide side um so everything i'm
going to talk about today is around
peptides but we do also have a
metabolomics lipidomics
group that does a very similar workflow
for assays around metabolites and
that are there also biomarkers and in
the clinical assay you know we look at
really very focused targeted
quantitation very low end so just a few
analytes that we do full quantitation
with full standard curves and
a lot more rigor than say you would do
this more target discovery assay
so the panel that i'm talking about
today is actually a published panel i'm
going to be presenting the published
part of it there there are more pieces
to this
panel but i'm not able to share those
with you so i'll just be sharing the
published portion of the the panel that
we'll be talking about today and um this
panel actually came from
someone
from the zetterberg lab who's someone
that is on our scientific advisory board
um the paper that it came from was a
showed in at all and it was published in
2019 um and in that paper they they
looked at eight proteins there were 52
tryptopic peptides that they were
wearing
and what so here you can see kind of a
list of some of these lesiosome
proteins that they were monitoring and
we actually i i drew up a little uh
association map here so you can see sort
of how
some of these proteins are associated
together and where they kind of link
together in the network
and then um
from there the their lab actually
generated
the these data sets and so these data
sets that we're looking at
are are around single time point
analysis for large cohorts of studies
and so these are disease-specific
cohorts and they actually took this
lysosomal dysfunction panel and looked
at a number of different
uh
disease areas including
um healthy normal controls pe
um so parkinson's disease and then also
alzheimer's disease and
um
what they found in looking at these
really sort of large cohorts was uh was
a pretty
good significant uh
19 of the 52 peptides and the data
itself
itself
because it's single time and so i think
you know you really need very large
cohorts to find the significance i think
um one of the
one of the things that we don't do is
single time point analysis and mainly
it's because you do need such large
numbers of samples and so um the the
difference that's one of the key
differences in the way that we look at
this panel internally versus the
published data is that we were actually
focusing on doing change from baseline
measures which are a little bit easier
to interpret and need a much lower and
defined significance
um
but but here you can see that in their
analysis they found a number of peptides
that that were that were um
significant
and that some of them were very disease
state specific um
one of the things that popped out here
is this apoe an apoe status shows a
direct correlation with ad versus other
diseases which i think is already fairly
well known um so they was reiterating
that that data
and so
how do we kind of adapt this method um
so we took this method it was a very um
it was a lot more academic method it was
a really good method but
we we kind of took it or i i
interpreted the way that it was being
done from the lab and
really attempted not only to add some of
our own internal analytes to it but then
to
automate it and make it as high
throughput as possible so that we could
process larger numbers of samples and so
to do this um i employed a number of
steps in the automation process so we
have an
uh bravo assay map in our lab and so
we we utilize that to do all of our
protein digestion as well as our
standard
edition which we use this little mantis
robot for and then posted post uh
digestion we actually do our cleanup
step on that assay map as well using the
rps column and i'll talk a little bit
more about that in a few slides um
and then we of course dry the samples
down we add our final set of standards
um which we use the irt standards to
help um track mass spec performance in
the assay and then we run them over our
6495c triple quad
in high flow mode with an ags ajs
source
so we're using a 2.1 by 150
uh length column and then we do all our
processing within skyline so all of our
data looks similar to this and and we
use all our data metrics exported from
here and we give them to biometrics and
they do the the final analysis for the
clinical samples
for all of our in vitro work that's all
done
in another group but it's the same
output
so one of the things that we wanted to
do
after
automating this with automating this
assay was to establish some really good
qc metrics um i think it's one of the
most critical parts for these complex
proteomic panels is to have the ability
to track and qc the data throughout the
process and so one of the first things
that we did was we decided to add an
internal digestion control something
that we spike in in the beginning
once we have the csf thawed or the
samples thawed we spike in this internal
digestion control it's a non-human
synthetic protein
and we monitor two tryptic peptides from
this assay we've actually updated this a
little bit and we we had these peptides
made in a stable isotopically labeled
form so that we could actually look a
little bit more accurately at these
peptides and track them
with a with a better ratio standard to
understand what our what our actual
recovery is
and then
then on the top right you can see
uh we we run a plate qc and so
this plate qc is actually a set of
pooled samples um whether it's a
biomarker csf cohort or some sort of
cell um cell cellular like lysate
experiment we create a pool of those and
then we run those with all of the other
samples so that we can see how it tracks
over time to make sure that we're
getting uh efficient chromatography as
well as efficient recovery of the the
analytes as a over time so that the
system's working correctly but then also
that the the
digest is also working correctly
and then in the bottom you can see that
we actually monitor
these irt synthetic peptides and so
these are sides that we purchased from
diagnosis and there are other people
that make them um we spike these in
right at the end and they actually help
us to monitor the system performance
over time and so you can see system
drift with these
um and they give you really just a flat
readout of what the the lcms system is
doing and so these are all really
critical and um the way that we
visualize these through skyline is that
we actually use autoqc
and we push these to our lab key server
and look at them in panorama and then
you can get
an output over time so it's a it's a qc
metric
that is is
really interfaced so that everybody can
look at so we share this data throughout
the labs that anybody who's running an
assay can look and see how the
performance of their assay versus all
other assays is and then they can also
download their own data if they want to
process it themselves
and so
after we did all this we decided that we
were going to then look at some
qualification or like a little mini
qualification since this is not a fully
um
validated app we're just doing some some
pretty basic methods of qualification
um and what we found was that the the
automation of this assay as well as the
the qc's allowed this to be a really
highly reproducible
um
assay that gives us confident ratio
metric measurements of protein changes
and samples and so we actually qualified
for this asset
the biomarker version of this assay
which was in csf at three different
volumes um 25 50 and 100 microliters of
csf um we looked at a number of
different things in terms of stability
including freestyle cycles auto sampler
stability room temperature stability we
looked at dilutional linearity
hemolysis
and so i've just provided you know on
the right side some output from the 25
microliter
qualification that we did and so you can
see like one of the peptides that i
pulled out you can see the the peak area
ratio across 30 replica injections you
can also see the bottom the retention
times and how really just very tight
they are across all these injections
and so i've also provided some qc values
here at 25 microliters
we had of the 81 analytes that were
measured 2430 measures at 25 cv
we had roughly 28.4 fail reproducibility
of 25 microliters which was about what
we had expected because there are a
certain number of analytes
that at 25 microliters we cannot detect
um which was roughly 30 of them
um and so and so that gave us the
detection statistics um so that when we
do this assay we understand what
analytes we can detect at each specific
volume so we know that at 25 microliters
we get roughly 75 of the peptides uh 50
microliters we see roughly 85 and then
at 100 microliters we see greater than
95 of the peptides
at a cv of less than 25 there's still
um a few peptides associated with
certain proteins that we do not have
high confidence at even at 100
microliters and and
those those peptides were removed so so
that we don't have to um
so this number actually goes to 100
so one of the things that um
it was really really critical for us
when we were doing this this
qualification um when we started the
qualification of 25 microliters we were
doing a pretty fast gradient for this
number of analytes at 30 minutes
um and we found that when we went to uh
to the larger volumes of csf we were
having a really hard time getting the
same sensitivity we were actually losing
quite a bit of sensitivity and um so i
started playing around with the gradient
i i was hoping to keep it at a shorter
time but we ended up having to make it
much longer so we had to double the
gradient time but in doing so that
actually um helped us quite a bit it
increased the protein
the increased protein load really
dictated that we needed it but um
the higher volume actually increased the
chances in the um of seeing the changes
in more proteins because we were able to
get up to that number of uh 90 greater
than 95
by extending the gradient prior to that
we weren't seeing anywhere near that
number at 100 microliters just due to
the fact that
we couldn't separate everything and get
away from the noise
that was being generated by having so
much background in such a compact um
gradient
so so this was incredibly important for
us it look it did lower our throughput
overall but i think the gain in terms of
overall sensitivity is worth that that
loss and throughput
but it's something to keep in mind when
you when you are developing these types
of assays is that they're not
necessarily very fast because you have
so many analytes they are they do
consume a lot of instrument time
um so so that's that's one of the one of
the biggest challenges for us in the lab
is um you know getting researchers to
understand that when they submit samples
they're not going to have their answer
in like say three days because we're
running like a three minute gradient but
you know it's going to take probably
three days just to run all their samples
so
and then from there i'm going to talk a
little bit about the actual sample prep
and
you and we like i said previously and we
wanted to automate this and we wanted to
use our assay map for this
um and so
in doing this this
ramp up in the automation one of the
things that we found
was that using the the standard five
microliter bed volume cartridge for the
rps
um cartridge that the assay map uses to
do c18 spe cleanup um we were we were
getting
mute like we were getting basically
reduced recovery at higher volumes of
some peptides which
kind of makes sense because
as you increase the overall protein load
you're going to probably see a decrease
in in
the capacity of the column to certain
analytes and so basically that's what we
were seeing and so on the left-hand
graph here you can see that um what you
would think
what you might think you would see
especially in some of these peptides um
say like the third one in or this like
six one in where where you're not seeing
any increase once you
of the the peptide intensity as you add
more volume um
we were actually able to recover that by
going to what are these sort of beta
assay map columns i know that
agilent has released 25 microliter bed
volume
columns for protein a and i believe
strep aventin
but they haven't released the rps ones
yet
and and so steve murphy was actually
great
and we i've been working with him for a
long time and he really helped us with
this and he sent us some some data
columns at the 25 microliter bed volume
to test out and they made an enormous
difference and so you can see um
kind of as we overlay here you can see
that you know at 25 microliters of csf
and the 5 microliter versus the 50 and
100 you actually start to see this this
in this recovery um which is really what
we what we want to be seeing here you
know you can see this you know like this
third one if you compare it with the
previous graph you're seeing
a much larger amount of recovery that
would be indicative of the increase in
volume that you should be seeing so
we're not having a capacity issue
anymore and when you really sit down and
look at it and you compare
the recovery um between say like the 50
at 5 microliter versus 105 microliter
you
once you start putting them on top of
each other you can see where um the 25
microliter bed volume column really
makes a huge difference because you do
start to see
um it it
these these substantial gains and
recovery that we're all due to the
column capacity
and so i mean one of the main things
that that we you know we've always
thought
with the assay map was that the some of
the five microliter columns weren't
necessarily
the right format for for some of these
analysis that had high protein content
especially for csf
because in csf analysis you typically
need much larger volumes than you need
same plasma or blood and so this this
actually going to these higher 25
microliter bed volumes really really
helped us out a lot it gave us
the the dynamic range that we we needed
without having to go offline to do um
offline sp which i was really wanting to
avoid because it it puts a really large
burden on the people in the lab doing
doing the sample preparation
so now let's look at some data um
so
here i'm looking at just you know really
this is just four samples
this is sort of what i was allowed to to
show but but what i did was i just took
a set of samples one healthy normal
control and then three pd csf samples
and we looked at a comparison and the
differences of
specific peptides from the multiplex
panel and again these are just
individual time points so you can't
glean too much information from them but
what you can tell is on the left hand
side you have
a number of proteins that show
some decreased
quant or you know decreased peak ratio
which could be indicative of lower
protein concentrations
by
um by stratifying by disease right so
the healthy normal control is this this
big green marker on the left here and
then the next three are all the pd
patients and so like for this ubiquitin
peptide you can see that the healthy
normal control on the left is much
higher than the other three um the same
thing for lamp two tpp one fouca fuco
and then app um this is one of the i
think four app peptides that we measure
and to the same accord you can look on
the right hand side and you can see
where um comparing the healthy normal
control on the left to the pd patients
on the right that you can in some of the
patients you can see an increase and and
then in this one middle patient you
don't so there's actually a little bit
of a patient variability here too um in
some of these very interesting proteins
like you know co9 tco2 and and then uh
cathepsin d
so
so it was really very promising that we
were able to even in this just very
small
subset of samples see some some
differences in proteins of interest um
and in in the expanded analysis we
definitely see a lot more of this so you
know this is really promising i'm i've
been really happy with the performance
of this so far and as a biomarker assay
in human csf and and we've implemented
it in in a number of studies so far and
that the data is still being analyzed
internally but um i'm pretty confident
in the quality of the data and hoping
that it will really help us to start
finding some some good biomarkers
uh associated with these pathways for
parkinson's
um
so the next thing i'm going to talk
about is how we started adapting this
panel for uh for in vitro work as well
so um on the discovery side of our
organization
there's a lot of work that's done in
cell models
and and so
you know we look for biomarkers as early
as possible and trying to trying to
interrogate these these pathways we
really want to
see if we can um implement this as early
as possible to to see what kind of
movement we're looking at in terms of
proteins of interest
and so um we we've started working a
number of cell lines and so some of the
data i'm going to show you just from one
of those um and we're actually able to
detect majority of the proteins um in in
even just 25 microliters of lysate so
roughly 30 000 cells and um we've
actually been able to go down to a
thousand cells and actually get really
good data for this pretty reproducible
across uh roughly
27 of the 33 and i think there are a few
proteins in the in the original
biomarker panel that
are more blood-based and so i'm not sure
that we'll it's it it's pretty clear
that we're not going to see those in
cell lysate so i think this this number
is actually really 27 and 27 because i
think there's a few of them that we just
won't see in the cell lysates we also
try to look in media that that's a lot
bigger challenge just because of the num
because the amount of background protein
that's in there and um so in 25
microliters of media we're really only
able to see a handful of
proteins um some of it could be just
because the proteins aren't actually
expressed out of the cells um
but we're we're working on that you know
there's there's still some more work
that we need to do to look at say maybe
albumin depletion or if there's a way to
do a dilution series or to remove the
albumin to get at some of these analytes
but you know this is ongoing work but
it's very exciting that we're able to
apply this
this panel also to to these more early
early projects because it allows us to
get away from just doing a lot of
hypothesis generation and actually
answer some questions with with proteins
that are of great interest to us
halfways that we're trying to modulate
and so um just looking a little bit
further at the data that we've gotten
from our in vitro models um you know
that the
there's a there's actually a lot of
excitement around this because we are
able to see by looking at say certain
certain knockout states with certain
treatments versus sailing that you can
see both um
you can see recovery upon treatment
with you know in these different
knockout states and so
it's really this is great because it
allows us to do these in a higher
throughput than say developing a number
of singleplex or even like low-end
multiplex immunoassays
um you know developing a lot of amino
acids the screen for all the proteins
that we have in these panels is
incredibly expensive and very time
consuming and often doesn't actually
work
which is not that surprising
so having this is a really powerful tool
because it allows us to
to really validate some of these markers
that we're interested in pretty quickly
i know that a 60-minute run time doesn't
seem quick but when you think about the
amount of time that it took us to
develop this versus say developing a
you know 35
roughly immunoassays this is a lot
faster so
um
this is nice it really um helps us out a
lot in terms of biomarker uh
biomarker analysis early biomarker
analysis but then it also gives us
some pathway specificity to in um
protein changes within the appropriate
models so we can see you know modulation
of lysosomal proteins and knockout
models um
towards you know wild tribe you know
with treatment but we can also see that
some proteins don't show treatment
effects which is actually really
important for us to know um so so this
is again this is great this is a
fantastic application of this that that
you know we're really happy about and
took very minimal uh changes to the
actual method to get to this so that was
even that was even nicer
and so lastly i'm gonna wrap up here and
um kind of highlight uh you know
you know what we've sort of learned so
far at denali from building these these
highly multiplexed assays and that
they're incredibly useful tools for the
interrogation of cellular and in vitro
systems um
the data from our triple quad analysis
shows ample sensitivity for analytes in
our and even in the sub nanogram per ml
concentration range we're able to
multiplex analysis
for higher throughput versus singleplex
or low multiplex amino assays um
and then
it you know in the 18 proteins shown
here that that that's you know we're
able to do 18 proteins versus say three
to six in an amino acid and then
um our method development is is a lot
faster by lcs versus amino acid with
fewer reagents we don't need antibodies
and then proteins and peptides can
actually be added or removed really
easily
we can we can subset these panels to to
fit the analysis that we need very
easily once we've qualified the proteins
or peptides and so that actually also
speeds up a lot of this and makes makes
for um
custom tailoring these these assays to
individual
projects a lot easier
and then automation of the routine
process decreases the variability
increases our throughput and it reduces
the manual steps for the users
and so it takes a lot of the processing
out of the hands of the biologists which
is great because that actually really
tightens up
the
the um
the data that we get at the back end i
think having more having too many users
putting samples into a process really
hinders the usefulness of the process so
so automation is really important for
for these types of things
and then um
lastly these multiplex protein panels
have a lot of utility in the biomarkers
in biomarker selection but also pathway
modulation
and so with that i would like to just
acknowledge the number of people that
have really helped me in the lab um you
know kirk is is my supervisor so he's
been really supportive of this um
catherine joined my group at the
beginning of this year and she's been
instrumental in helping to get all the
automation up and running um and then
jung and his group on the metabolomic
side jungus
provided a lot of support on the data
analytics and then the rest of these
people are all people who have had
contributions in some way shape form
over the life of this project and so
with that i would like to say thank you
and i'll take any questions
and thank you paul for that informative
presentation
now we will turn to our q a portion of
the webinar and i just want to remind
our audience members to go ahead and
submit some questions if you haven't
already in that q a box to the left of
your screen so let's take a look it
looks like we already have a couple
questions coming in
our first one paul did you perform any
untargeted discovery work prior to
building this panel
uh hi yeah um i just wanted to say too
thank you to agilent for um for giving
me this opportunity to present uh the
data that i have um but yeah so um
around that question we did um so so
this is um this panel is actually kind
of a
hodgepodge of things you know we use
the data or the you know the data from
our external um scientific advisory
boards lab but then we also use a lot of
internal data to build the panel uh it
was
uh it came to us through a number of
mainly through
dia analysis uh we did a number of um
untargeted discovery
uh analyses on on different types of
samples and
were um
and and so yeah so
long story short yes we did use a number
of untargeted
discovery
experiments to help build the the total
panel that we are running internally
thank you so much
and our next question
see that you mentioned the panel you
currently run is larger than what you
have presented what is the final size of
the panel you currently run
uh um so uh
the
we run so the total number of peptide or
protein analytes that we run
um is is 33.
there's there so 33 proteins of interest
we all
contamination
proteins that we monitor
mainly to see uh you know if there's
hemolysis in the samples it helps us
also to understand
how that hemolysis might affect
um other analytes in the panel and then
we you know there's the control proteins
and stuff so in total
um there's 38 proteins we have 83
peptides
um there's 164 precursors and then i
believe there's like 500 and
like 10 or 11 transitions
so it's a it's a pretty beefy panel
there's a lot of stuff going on um you
know we we had to utilize
uh scheduling
um
and i think that that you know in one of
the slides i showed um how tight the
chromatography was over a certain number
of runs and
and that's one of the really critical
things with you know these types of
assays because they're so
large and there's so many transitions
because you know typically with a
peptide you're monitoring
you know
unlike a small molecule with a peptide
you're monitoring multiple transitions
per per precursor um you really you know
you need to have a very tight
uh scheduling window and good
chromatography so so yeah so
there's a lot of analytes in this
in this panel
paul thank you again for your
presentation and for your time today we
really appreciate that and value it i
know you're at work today working hard
would you like to provide any last
comments for our audience members before
we go
no i'm good but um thank you for having
me
and everybody enjoy your day
and as a reminder to our audience
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration thanks again to paul and to
everyone who participated in this
presentation we hope that you will check
out the agilent exhibit hall and enjoy
the rest of today's event
take care stay healthy stay safe bye bye
everyone